[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuseherinnen und
zuseher guten abend sehr geehrter herr
kollege blumegg dies ist unsere letzte
sendung der kollege blume geht weg sie
können dann übrigens den schlüssel da
hinten auf den tisch lege und das auto
das behalte ich nur das mal
klarzustellen es gibt auch der letzte
selber haben sie haben sie gesehen ich
habe das alles ja ich habe schon damals
so spannend ein bisschen berlin hat
entspannt ein bisschen sie haben sich
auch verändert und zwar wenn vielleicht
die maz dass man ab fährt dann sind wir
auch gleich was ich meine bitte ich habe
ihnen was mitgebracht und zwar passend
zum thema ich möchte dass sie und ich
und wir alle zusammen
einfach mal die klappe halten
sie meinen schweigen statt nicht reden
das ist für mich die beste gelegenheit
kann ich eigentlich kann es sicher kann
er kann hiermit noch einmal eine chance
hat keinen sinn er kann es in all diesen
jahren wäre sicherlich gut gewesen sie
hätten sich daran hin und wieder mal
gehalten was man vor allem den seen kein
zehn jahre schweigen sollen ich hab mich
überhaupt nicht verändert sie sich sehr
diese jahre waren für sie sind reden
nach den gleichen schwachsinn aber ich
sehe besser aus diese jahre waren nicht
gut zu hin muss man seine entschuldigung
bei einem respekt selbst ihre jacke ist
irgendwie dunkelbrauner na gut lassen
wir das ganz kurz zehn jahre wie sie
spurlos an ihnen wenn sie jetzt mal so
bilanz ziehen würden ja nicht jetzt für
uns vielleicht auch einmal meinen also
machen einen großen bogen also ja sagen
wir mal ich war ja heute mal ist es ja
die abschiedssendung es liegt ja auch an
mir ich gebe es ja zu ich bin war ich
auf dieser website wohin eigentlich
nicht hingehen sein dass die 75 würde
fällig sprüche wenn du vorne sprüche zum
abschied nehmen zu jedem anlass und
einer davon war zum beispiel abschied
ist der anfang der erinnerung ist das
schön
das stimmt habe ich meinen mund kann
lachen auch wenn das herz schreit hasst
ja weil ein kollege fand so das sind
einfach und billig ist dieses nick feld
nehmen dann werden
ich weiß sie gehen zur rtl sie kommt von
der bild zeitung gehen zu rtl aber am
ende ist das sozusagen ist das so passen
sie sich jetzt schon an oder nein ich
versuche ich versuche der der diese
sendung diese abschiedssendung eine note
zu geben zwischen haben und ich meine
sie wollen jetzt hier das ernst aus und
erhalten aber mir ist irgendwie ja ja
also wir können noch einmal gerne bilanz
ziehen ja gerade als ich passe auf dann
fange ich mal an ich helfen ich helfe
ihnen mal überhaupt auf die sprünge und
wir müssen über einen rock mit uns
gemacht hat das ist ganz wichtig das
machen wir dann gleich aber jetzt
natürlich kommen vom großen ins kleine
so zieht der alltagsphilosophie der
bekannte alltagsphilosophie roger wicker
abschied ist ein scharfes schwert das
oft so tief ins herz fährt auch nicht
schlecht ok darf ich jetzt noch mal ganz
ganz weit ich wollte eigentlich jetzt
mit so einer richtig tollen these
rauskommen und ja wieder mit ein
bisschen in die ecke drängen und so weit
ich finde es wirklich
ja tatsächlich natürlich ja klar
natürlich die dinge sind tatsächlich
schlechter kaufmann
sie haben das gesehen damals standen wir
als zwei junge weiß in ländern sie
kommen
das war doch mal aus wie ein mann ist
die letzte sendung ich habe ihn doch
würde ich niemals tragen niemals für
alkohol jetzt stehen wir hier als zwei
alte weiße männer waldorf und statler
sozusagen gucken zurück in die
vergangenheit und ich muss sagen ehrlich
gesagt wenn ich jetzt mal so eine liste
machen so große themen ja praktisch
letzte große thema amerika der westen
der praxis die demokratie in osteuropa
die russen die türken die chinesen
angela merkel das klima was weiß was ich
es ist tatsächlich alles voll den bach
runtergegangen letzten zehn jahren ist
das gar nicht aufgefallen also aus und
abschiedsschmerz vorbei vergessen als
wäre es eine richtige sendung glauben
sie wirklich dass es in einer glatten
linie abwärts gegangen ist oder daß
meine tierbeobachtung es ist so auf und
ab gegangen
es gab tolle wachstumsphasen an denen
der welt handelt die ganzen menschen in
deutschland ganz viele arbeitslose
profitiert haben und dann gab es krisen
die finanzkrise die flüchtlingskrise die
demokratiekrise jahr gibt es in manchen
ländern erodiert die demokratie und
gleichzeitig gibt es immer noch und das
fasziniert mich und das ist für mich
ganz ehrlich ironie aus der rote faden
dieser zehn jahre das eines nicht
totzukriegen scheint nicht so zu kriegen
ist in war er ist immer wieder leute
aufstehen und die freiheit wollen ist
und zwar die freiheit wollen wieder
meint fing auch kapitalismus wollen aber
lassen wir das mal für eine sekunde
beiseite sie wollen die freiheit sie
wollen immer das ist was sie kriegen sie
bloß nicht ja aber da hatten sie aber
sie haben recht sie nicht sie haben
oftmals zu oft schneider von arabischen
frühling bis jetzt weißrussland ist
übrigens auch nicht so toll gelaufen wie
wir haben sie empfinde ist das immer
noch besser als es vorher aber dass es
für den einzelnen menschen dort glaube
ich aber das interessante ist doch dass
trotz vieler rückschläge und vieler wenn
sie so wollen auf der halben strecke
liegengeblieben bewegungen dieser art
freiheitsbewegung die leute immer wieder
darauf zurückkommen irgendwas scheinen
sie doch in sich zu haben und zwar rund
um den globus dass sie das wollen und ja
dahin und sie das nicht doch und das
macht einen meister oder oder
meinetwegen also mindestens hell
ich finde ja auch nicht dass der der
mensch versagt hat die man das finde ich
jetzt auch ein bisschen prix posterous
sozusagen ein bisschen sehr hoch möglich
wenn ich mir das hier an
das würde die menschen sind alle
schlechter sie verdienen ist sozusagen
im orkus der geschichte zu so weit würde
ich jetzt ja gar nicht gehen
ich finde nur dass ich mal anders
regelmäßige zuseherinnen und zuseher
unserer sendung werden sich vielleicht
daran erinnern dass wir hier das ein
oder andere mal an dem punkt waren an
denen wir jetzt auch kommen nämlich der
punkt wo ich dem kollegen blume sagen
dass sie lauter symptome beobachten so
die türkei hoppla osteuropa ee drexhage
trump das ist ja doof china ulla so die
klimakatastrophe haben wir auch nicht in
den griff bekommen die migrations krise
hätte man kommen sehen wollten wir aber
lieber nicht hingucken und so weiter und
sie machen nicht you don't connect oder
dort für sie sind das immer lauter
einzelphänomen die gar nichts
miteinander zu tun haben denn ich hätte
ich sagen nein mann ich weiß sie sind
ein liberaler und das schätze ich auch
an das jetzt ohne ironie ich sind ja ich
habe großen respekt vor der liberalen
politischen ideologie ich fürchte bloß
dass sie dramatisch versagt hat vor den
realitäten unserer geschichte und auch
vor den realitäten der kapitalismus
erzeugt hat sie können damit im grunde
gar nicht hin denn hier fehlt ganz
kurzen ihnen fehlt das theoretische
besteck um die realität so wahrzunehmen
mit ihr umzugehen wie man ist die sie
meinen ich bin unter komplex und deshalb
gehe ich jetzt besser sein dass jetzt
die sich dem prinzip nein sagen dass sie
sind ein ideologe das lustige ist doch
dass der chor nahm am tag steigen die
große ideologie falle getappt ist und
sie sind darin komplett untergegangen
weil der erste gang gekommen ist es
wieder soweit mit dem telefon erreichen
sie höchstens gerhard löwenthal und ich
bin nicht sicher wer da noch ran geht
und das ist auch ein gutes omen dass das
bei ihnen steht man sie sind echt von
gestern meint übrigens ist das auch der
grund ganz kurzer zeit auch unsere
sendung jetzt eigentlich auch gut ist
dass sie vorbei ist weil sie einfach von
gestern sind
ich bin ich das komplett weg und jetzt
passt mir doch egal
das ist übrigens schweigen ein mund kann
lachen auch wenn das herz weint hat es
schon erwähnt
genau das ist jetzt nicht nur das lachen
nicht irgendwie was man aber in wahrheit
weint ihr herz weil ihnen was fehlt zum
beispiel belehrung wie jetzt sie kommt
sie sehen das ganze bei einer wie hegel
um das zu zeigen
unterkomplex ph sie sehen das als
mechanistischen weg nur nicht verkaufen
sondern sie sehen es bergab sie mal ich
und hegel und ja sie sind so ein kleiner
regeln wenn sie die frisur noch ein
bisschen noch einmal
es hat noch nie jemand glauben sie sie
das ist jetzt wenn sie so wollen zehn
jahre zufall dass das jetzt verfügt dass
dieses format jetzt endet wenn es in
acht monaten enden würde dann wäre würde
ich mal wetten joe biden us-präsident
und wir hätten den beleg dafür dass
dieses system in amerika zum beispiel
nicht kaputt zu für den augen drei
herren alles anders werden wir würden
wir mit diesem alten mann der wirklich
von vorvorgestern ist kein totaler
übergangs präsident joe biden bashing
keiner der beiden sendungen aber das
system hätte gezeigt dass ist ein
totalausfall wie donald trump war sogar
einen feind den es sich quasi als system
hinein geholt hat als demokratie einen
feind der demokratie ist an die spitze
zu wählen auch wieder ausschalten kann
auch wieder gut machen kann und dann mal
sehen wie es dann weitergehen dann wird
die welt nicht wie sie vorher war aber
immerhin würde man das sagt okay das
system hat funktioniert checks and
balances in den usa haben funktioniert
und ich meine natürlich können sie
donald trump den sehe ich eher als
zufall der geschichte insbesondere aber
noch nicht einmal die wahl gewonnen
hatte er hat nur genügend bundesstaaten
gewonnen aber papier ist also weg von
und ich glaube sie übersehen wie sehr in
der tat die geschichte meinetwegen auch
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung der
kapitalismus in wellen vorangeht
sie versuchen da eine gerade linie
reinzuziehen die ihrer meinung nach
unten zeigen muss und das bildet die
wirklichkeit nicht ab dass man sich
einfach nicht habe also was würden jetzt
die leute sagen die vor zehn jahren
arbeit als waren 2000 also 2010 die nach
der wirtschaftskrise
nach der finanz und wirtschaftskrise
arbeitslos sie meinen die leute sollen
wieder zurück gefallen sind muss ich
jetzt einschreiten sie meinen die leute
die noch groß geworden sind mit einem
halbwegs funktionierenden modell
sozialer marktwirtschaft wo sie die
hoffnung haben konnten die begründete
hoffnung irgendwann gut bezahlten job zu
kriegen es ihnen erlaubten gewisses
vermögen anzusparen und sich vielleicht
mal ein kleines häuschen zu kaufen sie
meinen die leute die dann gemerkt habe
nur scheiße jetzt gibt es zwar diese
ganzen arbeitsplätze
die bestehen aber nur darin dass ich
irgendwie amazon pakete aus fahren darf
und da gibt es keinen betriebsrat
außerdem kriege ich zwar mindestlohn
aber der wird mir gar nicht aus
beeindruckt ist sie dagegen vorgehe dann
werde ich einfach rausgeworfen und da
sie meinen diese leute ja das doch
gerade aber bei 1
die prekarisierung die prekarisierung
unseres gesamten sozialen systems die
sich sozusagen auf den ganzen globus
nach zehn jahren sich auf den ganzen
globus ausgedehnt hat und dieses ganze
wirtschaftswachstum was sie sagen das
stimmt da ist unheimlich viel geld
verdient worden aber das ist in die
taschen von ganz wenigen leuten gegangen
das ist doch aber haben sie wollen sie
rund um den globus in lahti armut will
eklatant abgenommen rund um den globus
in deutschland und china ja das hat das
mit der demokratie nichts zu tun und das
natürlich auch bitter für sie als ich
studiert habe habe ich noch wert
demokratien das ist meine letzte halo
ist letztlich habe ich auch noch was
sagen das ist ja auch eine frechheit man
ist höflich zu gästen die geht der
witzigen nicht wahr
das ist doch ein witz zu sagen ja das
hat jetzt hast du dieses kapitalismus zu
tun
sie sagen es ist ein lange linie die
geht nur bergab und ich sagte coco sieht
man das anders gibt aber bergauf
aber natürlich gibt es krisen und so
weiter und so fort aber ich finde es ist
doch dass die sammlung auf etwa wir
hätten noch stoff für zehn weitere jahre
streit bleibt ganz kurz was hat es denn
mit ihnen und mit mir gemacht unsere
erfahrung die wir gesammelt haben sagen
sie doch mal sagen das ist ja unfassbar
dass sie zur letzten sendung kommen und
nichts gelernt haben was habe ich zehn
jahre zehn jahren endet das hier also
nur da kann man noch mal fragen streit
ich habe mir zehn jahren mühe geben es
war ein erziehungsauftrag man hatte mir
gesagt da es ein mann der probleme tun
sie was
und ich habe gesagt ja und für 100000
kammer punkte habe ich mich zehn jahren
ein bemüht ihnen beizubringen das ist
hier ist man hat mir viel weniger dem
carport ist ein wunder was machen wir
jetzt
jetzt müssen jetzt über leighton jetzt
kannst du dir jetzt tanzen wir gleich
wir werden gleich werden wir werden das
gleich machen mag ist komplett von der
rolle machen wir jetzt noch machen
[Musik]
kennen sie alexis sorbas den film ja
wann schluss ist alles alles klar es ist
ja so urteilt zwei männer stehen am
strand und tanzen
wir können jetzt auch tanz nibelungen
müssen wir wir müssen noch viele viele
sendungen überstehen abstellen aber wir
kennen doch jetzt ein bisschen tanzen
haben uns zum beispiel opel ja anfassen
dann nächstes sie waren so sie waren so
emotional ja ich war so emotional das
habe ich mir auch gewartet deshalb
machen wir das jetzt
wer jetzt sein können sie nicht mehr
sich rausreden damit dass wir noch so
viele sendungen wir haben überhaupt
keine sondern mir also am gleis jetzt
einfach noch ein paar leidig machen es
bleibt also das onkel zu zweit über 20
ich habe nicht so darauf gefreut all die
jahre
vielen dank die eisenbahn darunter ist
alles fertig danke ich sage danke
sie können sagen sie können jakob zu mir
sagen also könnten blume zu mir sagen
sie wären da nicht sentimental wäre doch
man ich habe gefangene jahren tragen sie
ist wie ein mann war
also ja so wird aber okay wenn sie mir
dass du geben wollen was ich nicht
annimmt dann gebe ich ihnen immerhin den
nachrichten fuchs denn ich bei der
nachrichtensendung sie haben mich so
genannten sie haben mich oft den
nachrichten fuchs genannt weil ich immer
wusste was die beerdigung hat er über
sie lustig machen das haben sie bloß
nicht mehr schülerinnen also außer mit
dem einmal als ich das an hatte und sie
was über diese fragen wird gesagt haben
das ziemlich klein und deshalb bleibt er
sagt ja und ja sie haben gesagt dass wir
erst mal so kramer das ist 8 cm müssen
diese koalition fortführen sie müssen
der nachrichten forsche sein wollen sie
es alleine anziehen ich brauche aber ein
größeres fragen wir sehen aus wie ski
oder jüngere oder ältere der ältere
hatte aber trotzdem also danke danke für
die richter ein letztes mal blicken auf
die website mit dem 75 wurde von
abschieds gesten oder wie es hieß wenn
menschen auseinander gehen sagen sie auf
wiedersehen
so ist es
lesen sie wohl okay manchmal deren
schweigen doch besser gewesen
[Musik]